donc Notre Dame
moi je vais pas mentir alors à la fois
j'adore dormir avec quelqu'un j'aime
bien dormir seul quoi enfin j'aime bien
avoir la place dans le lit pouvoir être
tranquille ne pas avoir la solution moi
c'est le liquide achètes un immense
League comme ça tu peux te rouler 10
fois dans ton lit sans culotte
j'adore 90% du temps mais il y a 10% tu
aimes bien être tranquille
salut les amis petite vidéo en direct du
Mexique coucou on tourne la suite de 30
jours max 3 jours max le film de Tarek
elle voulait en profiter pour vous
remercier pour les 2 millions d'entrée
merci d'être allé voir alibi.com de ça
nous fait plaisir Julien ça nous fait
trop plaisir merci gros bisous
alors je suis au milieu du désert au
Maroc et je viens de tomber sur ce décor
de cinéma
qui est assez incroyable mais j'arrive
pas à reconnaître de quel film ça peut
être
peut-être que peut-être que vous vous
avez trouvé
allez je vous montre
le pire je pense que c'est de s'être
quitté en s'aimant on sait même pas dire
au revoir quoi on sait même pas 10
bonnes continuations c'est très
compliqué quand même en lieu public
parce que ça dégénéré très souvent quand
vous êtes avec votre petit copain dans
la rue et que vous avez des gens qui
vous insulte lui et furieux de ce dont
on vous accuse et vous insulte donc en
vie vraiment dans les frapper les gens
donc c'était très très compliqué pour
lui d'exercer un métier